Dad what are you doing? What I
should have done long ago
Welcome back everyone this will be my full
dc peacemaker episode 7 video there's a whole
bunch of easter eggs so we'll break it all
down if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get everything there's a
bunch of big dc stuff happening this weekend
they just released a super bowl trailer for the
movies so i'll be doing a video for that next too
real quick shout out to my friends at kamikoto
knives who asked to sponsor this video i'm doing
a giveaway for these special knives they sent
me i'll pick a winner from the comments on this
video after a few days and give them a shout
out in a separate video later this week kamakoto
makes these amazing japanese steel kitchen
knives using traditional techniques from japan
they build on this legacy of over 800 years of
japanese technology and expertise in creating the
steel to make knives that have been meticulously
handcrafted using traditional techniques that date
back to the edo period of japan if you watch the
demon slayer anime series or read the manga that
takes place during the edo period of japan between
the 1600s and the 1800s each knife goes through a
rigorous 19-step process that takes several years
from start to finish to complete kamikoto is so
confident about the quality of their knives that
each one comes with a lifetime guarantee they make
a ton of different types of knives the set that
i'll be giving away is part of a three-piece con
peki set that comes with a nakiri vegetable knife
a slicing knife and a smaller utility knife they
ship in this special heavy duty ash wood box that
doubles is a really good storage case too i'll add
a link for their store page in the description
below so you guys can get 50 off if you purchase
by using the discount code that they gave me
i'll put it on screen here it's kamakoto.com
emergencyawesome so be sure to check them out
careful for spoilers from the episode if you
haven't seen it yet we'll start at the beginning
and work our way through shot by shot talking
about easter eggs moments as we go along starting
with the episode title stop dragging my heart
around a reference to peacemaker's father white
dragon in the way he's been abusing him physically
emotionally since he was a child manipulating him
which sort of feeds into peacemaker's realization
that his brother's death wasn't his fault he
finally comes to terms with that he realizes his
father is the one who's truly responsible for the
death of his brother even though he's the one who
accidentally killed him the actual opening scene
is the full reveal of what happened to his brother
it starts with them both listening to that same
motley crue song the peacemaker was just playing
on the piano at the end of last week's episode
in fun fact if you didn't realize this john cena
actually does play the piano in real life so
he was really playing that song on that piano
while they were filming it but the song was motley
crew's home sweet home so they're jamming out to
that in the past in their records just having
fun rocking out like a couple little kids his
brother even seems like he could care less about
their father's whole dogma the whole kkk of it
all like screw that let's just rock out and get
chicks that's why peacemaker loves hair metal
music in present day so much because emotionally
he's kind of frozen at that point in his life
the last time that he was really happy before his
brother died and when his brother literally says
let's smoke all day and just tongue kiss hot babes
literally that's what peacemaker has been doing in
all the episodes when he's slowly broken down
emotionally to the point of crying on the floor
they also confirmed my theory about the way his
brother died his father forced them to fight so
that he could earn money off of them and he just
accidentally killed him with a punch to the head
in exactly the wrong place with just enough
force but the whole idea here is that their
father white dragon liked the brother more
than peacemaker and spent the rest of his
life letting him know every chance he got and just
generally treating him like a piece of crap until
peacemaker finally calls him out on it and kills
him the way robert patrick said that james gonna
explain the character to him the white dragon
character before they started filming is that
he was designed to be so vile just to explain how
peacemaker could be so messed up in present day
they do further the butterfly plot in this
episode but the episode is mostly designed to be
peacemaker vs white dragon the butterflies had
just taken over the entire police station the
prisoners from the jail because they absorb human
memories they learned all of the team's plans from
a lock who knew that mirn was planning to destroy
their cow alien so the butterflies engineered this
plan to create a teleportation device to transport
their cow to another secret location and it is a
massive alien cow although the term cow is kind
of misleading it's just like a giant butterfly-ish
blob creature that they milk for that special
honey the actual alien cow itself looks like
something inspired by james gunn slither movie if
you were getting slither vibes from this that's
probably on purpose if you've never seen that
movie it's a sci-fi horror movie that he directed
really early in his career about this alien
parasite species that comes to earth and
starts taking over the population doesn't that
sound familiar wait a minute oh wait that's
what the butterflies are doing on peacemaker
and the way they describe it it's the only
one on this planet and the butterflies don't have
another way to replace it so they kill it they
kill their food source they kill the butterflies
judo master escapes again hilariously he's not a
butterfly but he was working for them i love
that the first thing that he does is go for
another bag of flamin hot cheetos they're like
his kryptonite the cheeto jokes on peacemaker
are kind of like the fresca jokes during
the boys season two would you like a fresca
white dragon reveals he's got all of his hypertech
and peacemakers helmets lojacked and they use
the trackers to find him but by the end of the
episode now that peacemakers killed his father
i do wonder if heading into a possible season two
or just more peacemaker crossovers and future dc
hbo shows and movies he'll just stop wearing those
helmets all together or if he'll commandeer all
of his father's folding space pocket dimension
just because that place has all the hypertech
gear that the team would ever need for any kind of
future missions together because now that mern's
dead harcourt has kind of taken over leadership
of the team it seems like the vibe will be if
they do get a season two they'll just continue to
exist as they do now at the end of this episode
maybe add like another suicide squad character
to the roster like another c or d-list funny
character that's kind of a villain either way
i just hope they don't let all of white dragons
hypertech gear go to waste it also seems like
amanda waller if she found out about this place
would really want to get her hands on all this
gear does anybody need a pocket folding dimension
just feels like we could put that to some good
use like even batman doesn't have a pocket
folding dimension inside the bat cave peacemaker
reveals that although the diary is fake and full
of terrible collages he would totally love to
make a diary with collages that are actually
good he also enjoys journaling learning all kinds
of little details about peacemaker along the way
leota finally comes clean to the team about all
of her secrets the fake diary she planted the
fact that she's amanda waller's daughter but
the funny thing is is that harcourt totally
figured out what happened with the fake diary
on her own and confronts her about it and mirn
knew that she was amanda waller's daughter the
whole time and didn't tell anyone her whole story
arc is about balancing herself in the morally
gray area where all suicide squad-based stories
operate they keep referencing how she has a talent
for this kind of work she's a chip off the old
amanda waller block so she'll probably continue
with the team after the finale should they get
a season two and just be more sure of her choices
and actions on missions she won't hesitate as much
the same way that peacemaker had that brief
existential crisis in the middle of the series
but now he's more sure of himself like he doesn't
have a problem killing the right kind of people or
the right kind of bad people she makes a reference
to mars attacks that's a movie about aliens from
mars invading kind of like the butterflies from
another planet are invading earth then when the
two douchey kids at the convenience store start
going on about how good boondock saints is they're
right boondock saints is an amazing series i think
they included that reference in the show just
because james gunn is a fan of that series in real
life white dragon and his posse take out their van
his suit is meant to be hardcore hypertech he
doesn't care about the other team members he's
really just here to kill peacemaker and he'll
just mow through the others to get to him but
here's the thing vigilante definitely makes up
for being such a weirdo this whole time winds up
being super useful during this whole white dragon
fight the couple white dragon fights to take place
across the rest of the episode like the first time
he stops him shorten his tracks using his guns and
his bombs the second time they finally pay off his
earlier observation inside the folding space about
white dragon's armor weakness the cloth portions
between the armor plating sticking him with the
knife disabling the suit saving peacemaker's life
yet again like he saves his life at least a couple
times in this episode but on the flip side of that
he also brought all those helmets which helped
white dragon track them down again in the episode
right after they escaped so having vigilante
on the team is kind of like a 50 50 situation
he's a savant with weapons he's amazing but he
also gets you into as much trouble as he gets you
out of when he takes off in the clan member's car
that he steals hilariously they played don't close
your eyes by kicks as he literally tries to keep
from passing out then when peacemaker uses the
raccoon to distract white dragon in his posse
they make a bunch of raccoon jokes and it feels
like it's mostly meant to be a guardians of the
galaxy rocket raccoon reference like economos says
he didn't expect this to happen when peacemaker
picked up a wild raccoon as if to imply raccoons
are way cooler than you think like rocket from
guardians also steve agee who plays jon economos
was one of the ravagers during the guardians of
the galaxy movies they're still in the middle
of filming guardians of the galaxy 3 right now
the actor who plays mirn is also playing a secret
new villain in guardians 3. the rumor is is that
he's going to be mcu high evolutionary but then
the butterfly queen brings her minions to kill
mern or they kill the butterfly that is mirn they
do give him this kind of funny but touching moment
with harcourt when it reaches out and touches her
just as it dies so r.i.p only james gunn could
get you to care about a little bug like this judo
master returns to get revenge on them it's a solid
action scene harcourt has had a couple good action
scenes this season but they're usually with guns
this is really like her first major brawl fight
love the way that leota just tases the crap out
of him too so he's still alive he can come back
in the finale it'll be interesting to see which
way he lands i'm sure they'll use him mostly for
some comedic action scenes he's still technically
working for the butterflies like they're paying
him but they're trying to take over the planet so
maybe he'll eventually help the team out or start
working for amanda waller after the finale if he
survives this whole scene of peacemaker running
out of the woods waving his arms wildly from the
clan members kind of feels like an indiana jones
raiders of the lost ark reference for the shot
of him running through the jungle just waving his
arms at the plane as the tribe is coming after him
we find out that vigilante pees like butters
from south park pulling his pants all the way
down to the ground because he's just that weird
when white dragon starts making all these weird
biblical references he talks about the story of
abraham that's the story of how god asked abraham
to sacrifice his son isaac to prove his faith
he almost did but god stopped him claiming that
he passed the test before he could finish landing
the killing blow so when he's saying 40 years ago
he was tested that was when peacemaker was born
peacemaker is meant to be 40 years old in the dc
eu it's why white dragon says he should
have killed him the moment he was born
when he's laying in a peacemaker he also kind of
reveals that he's bi that's what he meant when he
said the peacemaker laid with both men and women
but when he mentions the forces of bamfomet that's
actually the deity that's allegedly worshiped
by the knights templar but it is a dc character
inside the dc universe it's still worshipped by
the knights templar within the dc universe but
its main power is foretelling catastrophic events
and it's from the doom patrol comics the one the
white dragon is talking about in the context of
this episode mostly sounds like a metaphor for
the suicide squad itself and i think he's mostly
referencing the events of the suicide squad movie
in the starro mission with vigilante's help like i
said peacemaker finally kills his father stands up
for himself they save eagerly's life with the
help of these regular vets it's a very funny
sequence i love the way that leota also reacts
to eagerly hugging peacemaker in the very complex
very well thought out prayer peacemaker offers
god about sleeping with an ugly woman to thank
her for taking care of eagerly while he would
have been in prison the reason why he reaches
for his phone and takes another picture of them is
because he wasn't able to do that the first time
eagerly hugged him at the beginning of the series
he didn't have his old phone with him at the time
and vigilante also destroyed his old phone which
had a bunch of other eagerly photos on it so he's
just trying to fill up his new phone with a bunch
more to replace them love the way they totally win
the vets over with all their speeches and they
try to join the team just cocking the guns like
nope nope sorry that's not happening you're
not joining us you would just die you would
not be useful in this fight they make even more
butch cassidy sundance kid references they have
a really long drawn out argument about the plot
of that movie in the way that had a downer ending
so they'll probably wind up paying that off in
the finale in some funny way where the current
roster here of team members probably survive
i think the idea is that mirn was probably the
only team member that they planned on killing
off but we'll see them doing that slow walk to
camera is meant to be another guardians of the
galaxy slow walk reference because just like the
guardians this team is a group of total a-holes
that wind up saving the day also that kind of
pays off the apple dumpling gang reference from
earlier this season then the post-credit scene
this week is just a bunch of outtakes and funny
moments in bloopers from the police briefing if
you look closely in the background here you can
see one of the deputies behind him on the right
breaking and laughing in the middle of the scene
while he goes on and on just saying more and more
ridiculous random stuff it's important to swing
the hips and we're finished now thank you very
much thank you for attending but if you spotted
any other easter eggs in the episode that i didn't
mention in the video write them below in the
comments my full peacemaker episode 8 finale video
will post next week just like normal supposedly
there's going to be some crazy dceu cameo scene
so we'll see who winds up showing up james gunn
did say the peacemaker series would help set up
some future dc project so maybe that's what
he's talking about they also just released a
super bowl trailer for the dc movies so i'll do a
video for that next that should post by saturday
there'll be a couple marvel super bowl trailers
on sunday as well so i'll be doing videos for all
those things make sure you have alerts enabled
for my channel so you don't miss all those
everyone click here for my full mandalorian season
3 teaser in top 10 predictions and click here for
all my dc and marvel super bowl trailer videos
i'll update the link as soon as they start posting
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!